[Music]
i feel like i've survived
i like life i like life that's what it
is
and starred in dozens of tv series in
more than 40 movies including a remake
of psycho and six days seven nights with
harrison ford but her big acting break
came on the nbc soap opera another world
playing twins it's the hardest work
anybody could ever do
the role won ann a daytime emmy award
but it was her relationship with
girlfriend ellen degeneres that really
put ann in the spotlight they started
dating in 1997 the same year ellen
famously came out and brought anne to
the emmys welcome to the emmys i say
welcome to the emmys i say everybody
obviously she's a genius comedian we're
still so honeymoony we like to stay up
until four o'clock in the morning and
and talk about life they were together
for three and a half years one day after
their breakup in 2000 and was found
confused and disoriented after wandering
into a private home near fresno
california she said a voice told her to
take ecstasy she wrote about it in her
2001 memoir call me crazy
i was flat out and strapped on a gurney
in an all-white kind of cramped room
that seemed less than glorious as a
stopping point on my way toward heaven
i wondered if it was going to be
announced on tv or a loud speaker or
something she has arrived the spaceship
is on its way gather in fresno just off
the freeway what was going on
i escaped to the fourth dimension and
had been through a lot she had an
abusive father with a double life i
think my family story is
very disturbing
and i think some people would like that
reality to stay buried
i believe i was sexually abused by my
father from the time i was
a very young girl
actually before i could speak
up until the time i was 12.
dad died on march 4th 1983.
he was one of the first cases of aids
diagnosed in the united states
when you learned that your father had
aids
did you think
i might have aids absolutely but i
thought i was gonna die
she told abc news that to cope with her
father's abuse she escaped to a fantasy
world and another personality i called
my other personality celestia i called
the other world that i created for
myself the fourth dimension
i believed i was from that world i
believed i was from another planet
i think i was insane
anne's movie career may have diminished
but in the last few years she kept busy
with acting roles you protecting your
little girlfriend she recently starred
in the vanished for netflix and plays a
lawyer on the own show all rise and you
don't think that's going to get laughed
out of court the actress also appears in
the weekend's upcoming hbo series the
idol
e.t sat down with anne in 2020 after she
competed on dancing with the stars and
asked her about reconnecting with ellen
so if ellen does call you
what do you say to her
wrong
number oh can i call you back after i
have
a shot
ann was a mother of two she shared her
son homer with ex-husband real estate
agent coley lafoon and another atlas
with her ex and former men and trees
co-star james tupper
despite the pain of her past ann always
hoped sharing her story would help
others i lived a crazy life
i was raised in a crazy family and it
took me 31 years to get the crazy out of
me
to overcome difficulties in your life
and to understand that you can get to
the other side of them is is really what
my
what my hope is for people who have been
who've been raised in difficult
circumstances
you